high blood calcium. So the person just put in high blood calcium. So I'm thinking they're asking
what does that mean when we have high blood calcium. So calcium is a marker that will typically
be tested in a complete metabolic panel. It's obviously a measurement of calcium in the blood,
which is the mineral. Calcium in the blood acts as a buffer in the blood. Remember, we've talked
about this in the past that you have a brilliant buffering system in your body that so the idea
of, you know, we are, you know, going to alkalize ourselves by drinking alcohol and water.
We've talked about that that that doesn't make any sense physiologically. Because of this buffering
system, now we can be in a situation of acidosis or or two alkaline. And we're not buffering
correctly, but that's not and because of we need to drink baking soda or we need to drink, you know,
high pH water. It's because of imbalances in our buffering system. So high blood calcium or low
blood calcium would be an imbalancing at buffering system. And there'd be a reason for it. So if a person
had low blood calcium, it's usually a decrease in function gland that's called your your your
a thyroid gland. So next to your thyroid gland in your neck, you have two little glands on either
side that you that are called your para me next to thyroid glands. And they to create a hormone that
balances the calcium in your blood. So if you have an issue with that gland that can cause both high
and low blood calcium, there's a very common condition with the parathyroid gland. It's a tumor
of the parathyroid, actually quite common. A tumor of the parathyroid gland typically produces
high blood calcium. So if a person does not have a diagnosis of cancer and they have
all other normal values, but elevated calcium, that's the first thing that you want to investigate.
All blood work, all tests are just clues to something going on. It doesn't always give you a
definitive diagnosis. You have to dig into other things. So you would do an MRI or CT scan of the
parathyroid gland to see what's going on with the parathyroid gland. Now, if a person has a diagnosis
of cancer and they have elevated calcium levels, the parathyroid gland is not the first thing you think
of. The first thing you think of is metastasis to bone. So if a person has a diagnosis of cancer
and that cancer metastasis to bone, it's typically going to be lytic and it's going to have
destruction of that bone and spill calcium from that bone into the blood. Now, typically it would
also follow that in this same complete metabolic panel, that person would also show elevated
alkaline phosphatase. So that would be the other clue that you would look for. So a person shows high
blood calcium. You'd look for alkaline phosphatase, if that's elevated also, then you'd think of
destruction of bone in a person cancer, you'd think of metastasis. And that's what you look for.
But if the person had no previous diagnosis and they just showed elevated alkaline and it spared
the alkaline phosphatase, meaning that if alkaline phosphatase was normal, then you'd think of
parathyroid gland.